[Music]
sir it's time for you to stop this
unhealthy behavior no it's not you need
to take responsibility for your life
not right now I don't and it starts by
raising your son I'm sorry I literally
have no idea what you're talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the gala
remember Wow
stares he's been living here for the
past week
hello table and I must say I've grown
rather fond of the young
hello secret camera you should get to
know him you and he have a lot in common
doesn't he deserve a chance for someone
to take him under their wing as I took
you under mine Alfred you've been
watching way too many Lifetime movies
and drinking Chardonnay its Pinot
Grigios whatever it is
[Music]
what
it's the best game
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh Batman whoa
your turn right whoa wait just Batman
live in Bruce Wayne's basement no Bruce
Wayne lives in Batman's attic have
sleepovers every night no kid oh look
it's the bats up wait don't touch that
and over there it's the bat space
jockeys keep your hands okay that's a
plane don't touch that either that's me
no it's a bad kayak is the bat doom
Barney gets the bat shark repellent uh
actually you can you can't touch that
it's completely useless whoa thanks
Batman
Wow look at all these forget a costume
for the mission - I got a feeling that
you'll just look like a kid on Halloween
don't you think don't touch me hello
mariachi I like that one that one is
culturally insensitive take care of that
one no way this is deaf no okay
this will firestarter no piss Claude
Rains no blacks calabasa
Oh silent I'll gladly nope bath Krishna
tub
how do you feel about this one dress-up
parties are for grown-ups only wait
what's that one there well that one is
for the Simon called it to make a caper
the locals called me reggae Mon I love
it oh just like I was poured into this
my only trouble is these pants are just
a little tight I don't know if I could
throw a kick or jump in them I got an
idea
rip it's better now I'm free now I'm
moving come on Batman let's get grooving
I could only look you in the eyes right
I got you oh yeah well there's only one
problem
who's gonna defuse the bomb it's gotta
be one of the other Batman save the city
or catch your greatest enemy you can't
do both
I'm sorry what did you just say you
can't do both I said no I mean the other
thing save the city or catch your
greatest enemy
you think you might greatest enemy yes
you're obsessed with me no I'm not yes
you are no I'm not that's your worry
who else drives you to one-up them the
way that I do babe hell we does Superman
Superman still a bad guy could I say
that I don't currently have a bad guy I
am fighting a few different people what
I like to fight around
hey I was thinking if I'm gonna be a
superhero and gone awesome superhero
missions like this one can we use code
names yeah I could be Robin
I'm sorry say that again Robin as in the
small Midwestern Braille burg yeah I
already have a catchphrase
tweet-tweet on the street hard bass and
a song fly Robin fly harder pass no fine
okay kid I'm gonna teach you how to
master build your way inside that day
yeah grab those two high sixes pull out
the actual studs this kind of 6 by 10
plates whoa unbelievable obeying now
that's right look toast to the nose [ __ ]
now you're cleaning the queue now get
creative you freestyle or that dirt kid
it's like looking in a bat mirror okay
got the projector dad oh yeah yeah do
everything we just did backwards oh oh
here you go dad we did it yeah we should
accomplished it was fun sup bad fit
[Music]
obviously after I made the lego movie a
monster hit 468 million dollars
worldwide not done counting of course it
seemed clear to everyone that the world
needed more of me the Lego Batman movie
is a way for me to give back to my fans
with a glimpse into my real life of
fighting crime and brooding heroism I'm
blushing super hard under the mask prego
I think it's wonderful that the world
gets to see a different side of Master
Brooke
I mean Batman
but there's a lot more to Gotham's Dark
Knight that meets the eye
for instance did you know that Batman
has recently adopted a son
hello secret camera dick here looks up
to me in every way well of course I do
we are the best team ever he idolizes me
to know it I want to be just like you
when I grow up Padre little guy wants to
grow up to be a crime-fighting vigilante
superhero just like me
no matter how dangerous and illegal it
is look fat dad Sebastian but don't call
me Dad just go to your room okay oh I've
been parented we all know that Gotham
City has a long history of crime and my
dad did a great job cleaning things up
but that was then and this is now this
movie reflects a new Gotham City and my
Gotham City High where heroes can team
up and fight crime together I can wear
my costume too well luckily for us you
left your costume tagging room that's
perfect yeah the suits at the studio
thought my dark life of fighting crime
alone needed a few more heroes in it
even though I really don't need anyone
at any time ever to get them totally
awesome and Batman works alone come on
Batman let's get grooving fact is I'm a
team player so I said cool as long as
they don't bother me or touch any of my
stuff hey Batman I'm rubbing my butt all
over your stuff we're gonna have to
renamed as the butt mobile well
obviously I'm fat man's greatest enemy
no matter how much he may deny it so
when the studio asked me to be the main
villain in this movie I left it the
chance to work with him again I mean
let's face it there is no Batman without
the Joker we go together like coffee and
doughnuts lapell flowers and rubber
chickens mayhem and destruction and what
I love about this movie the most is that
it finally takes the time to explore my
sensitive side I mean yes I am a master
criminal slash improv comedy genius but
I'm also a nice guy and what's Batman
finally realizes this I won't be just
smiling on the outside I'll be smiling
on the ends like - that'll be a nice
relief and nobody's got a smile like you
mr. J Thank You Harley just wish Batman
would notice once in a while
ah I love it
[Music]
this movie has everything action scenes
chase scenes building cool stuff
explosions Batman running Batman
building events in the city I mean
everything it's about learning the value
of teamwork and family experience the
very emotional story of a young English
lad with a dream that he's held since
childhood to become the most popular
Butler the most famous Butler in motion
picture history it's the story of a
misunderstood criminal genius an epic
tale about one woman's bravery to
challenge a city and their hero and make
the world a better place in the end
everyone loves and respects me forever
which i think is important we're like a
bad family family might be a bit strong
I was gonna say more like me and my
biggest fans or you answer awesome team
it's called the Lego Batman movie just
saying oh you're such a great Padre what
are you doing trying to give you a big
old hug
are you were attacking me yeah Batman
why did you build this thing with only
one scene cuz last check I only had one
but
yeah it must be great to be Batman
thank you I'm blushing super are double
the mass imagine he's going home right
party the night away
surrounded by grand lady activewear
Marvel's master Bruce your greatest fear
is snakes nine thousand it's being a
part of a family again
no now it's snake clouds because you put
that idea in my head sir you need to
take responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
adopt me I thought I was being sarcastic
hello secret love is let's answer just a
little tight I gotta hear
it's better I can only look you in the
ice right now greatest enemy Superman is
my greatest enemy Superman's not a bad
guy and I'd say that I don't currently
have a bad guy I am fighting a few
different people I like to fight around
hi Barbara Gordon new police
commissioner it's my dream the police
force to team up with Batman what
wouldn't it be better I hate everything
you just said dish wise masterbuilder we
did it pretty cool why don't you build
this thing with only one seed just last
I checked I only had one bud
let's go defeat the Joker we're going on
a family trip
I can wear my costumes here well luckily
for us you have to cost you bagging
right
oh no under your clothes that's perfect
earned anything hey Vee
nope what have you learned about puppies
hey puppy
no Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey be back
the notes I can't read